ça sent bon le feu de bois l'éguille
décline est le clou de girofle et que ce
soit en version plateau branché ou place
de village ça flaire surtout bon la
convivialité marrons chauds vend les
choses c'est leur choix tout est chaud
c'est fait que c'est un peu cher je
pense que c'est zidane et de la chaleur
humaine dans un lieu qui est qui et
froid
le monde puis avoir des gars rassembler
j'avais bien versé par et l'a
probablement agathe sauriol est une des
pionnières des marchés noël au québec
celui qui l a ouvert il ya sept ans à
l'assomption dans lanaudière reçoit plus
de cent mille visiteurs par année soit 5
fois la population la petite ville on
attire des gens de l'extérieur qui
viennent ici pour la première fois puis
qu'on voit venir les marchés noël une
bonne affaire pour les villes pour les
quartiers pour les commerçants oui c'est
rentable
oui oui on peut mentir éclat et qui m'a
choisi norinder année hinan à l'institut
goethe on parle noël avec les étudiants
langue culture allemande
si au québec les marchés noël son tout
récent en allemagne ils apparaissent dès
le 14e siècle dans le bon vieux temps
c'était un marché pour acheter
pour acheter des produits avant l'avant
l'hiver alors un bon café pour choper
merci beaucoup les bénévoles
mais le fait que les marchés noël se
multiplient un peu partout chez nous n'a
rien à voir avec la survie alimentaire
mais bien peut-être davantage avec la
survie d'un tissu social ronge croire au
père noël magique et rila les gens
veulent se poser les gens veulent
échanger ces sonos l esprit dresser la
rencontre donc puis l'ouverture à
l'autre qu'on croyait qu'un marché de
quartier larcher citoyens mais remplir
ces fonctions là et au rythme où vont
les choses le québec deviendra peut-être
bientôt un autre de ces endroits du nord
où il fait bon boire du vin chaud
ensemble